Everyone has different tastes in movies, but
now and then a film comes along that just
defies understanding no matter which way you
slice it.
Whether it's a high-concept art film or just
the product of a ridiculous plot, these movies
stick around for one reason: they leave us
more confused than ever when the credits finally
roll.
Spoilers coming up!
Inland Empire
David Lynch's 2006 film Inland Empire is an
insane sort of beast.
A three-hour nightmare of a movie featuring
Hollywood, street prostitutes, and a super
weird sitcom about rabbits, it makes Mulholland
Drive look like an episode of Friends.
It's also as close as Lynch has ever come
to making a full-on horror movie, providing
scares more startling and perplexing than
he's ever dared before.
But what does it actually mean?
According to The Guardian, it's "about whatever
you come away thinking it's about."
So... looks like you got this one right!
The Prestige
Christopher Nolan's movie about dueling magicians
is pure cinematic sleight-of-hand, a mystery
that keeps all its clues in plain sight.
Still, there's one aspect of the movie—the
ending—that continues to leave viewers confused.
The ending shows the length Angier will go
to for his magic when Christian Bale's Borden
discovers a macabre storeroom of Angier's
own dead, duplicated bodies, still in the
boxes where they drowned during each performance.
But who is the real consciousness, and the
real Angier?
It's a brain-twister, but Tesla revealed the
answer before the final act of the movie,
when they discover the field of cloned hats.
"Don't forget your hat."
"Well, which one is mine?"
"They are all your hats, Mr. Angier."
All of the Angiers are the "real" Angier,
exact copies who share the exact same memories,
motivations, and a fear of death.
Over and over again, he dies for applause,
always leaving behind a living copy of himself
who's doomed to drown screaming in a box the
following show.
Having a twin would have been so much easier.
Under the Skin
This alien abduction movie is unlike any other
in the sci-fi genre.
It's truly only an abduction movie for the
first half—after which the alien, played
by Scarlett Johansson, becomes disillusioned
with luring humans into traps.
When she decides to let one victim go free,
the alien goes rogue, curious about this planet,
its people, and her role as an alien in disguise.
The second half of the movie follows the alien
trying to grapple with a growing sense of
her own humanity, and the vulnerability that
comes with it.
Her journey is cut short when a lumberjack
tries to rape her in the woods.
But when Johansson's human skin starts coming
off, the attacker burns her alive.
Look past the sci-fi aspects, and this is
essentially the story of a young woman's self-discovery—and
her devastating, fatal realization that the
human world is harsh, unfair, and full of
horrors.
Gerry
Gus Van Sant's Gerry is basically a movie
about nothing.
It's about two guys named Gerry who get lost
hiking in the desert.
They wander around the endless landscape,
blaming each other for their screwups, until
one Gerry kills the other Gerry and gets out
of the desert.
It's dry stuff, and in the end, the movie
doesn't do anything.
But that's really the point of it: the two
protagonists could be anyone, and their journey
could be to anywhere.
In this way, Gerry is sort of a universal
story, serving as a mirror for viewers, reflecting
the petty conflicts and the damage we do to
each other and ourselves—and finally, yes,
the overwhelming boredom of life.
Filth
Starring James McAvoy as corrupt cop Bruce
Robertson, Filth starts off as a comedy and
murder mystery, then steadily veers off course
into a film about psychological torment.
The tonal shift is so dramatic that it's no
surprise viewers can end up losing track of
the plot, particularly during the last-act
reveal that Bruce has been spending his nights
roaming the streets dressed as his own estranged
wife.
While on one of his cross-dressed jaunts,
he witnessed the murder he's supposed to solve—a
fact he can't reveal without incriminating
himself.
In the final moments of the film, even though
Robertson has a shot at redemption, he chooses
not to fix anything and hangs himself—the
ultimate kiss-off from a selfish, self-preserving
man.
Eraserhead
David Lynch's bizarre first feature film is
a little easier to comprehend than its reputation
suggests.
At its core, it's a story about the terror
of being a new parent.
From the opening scene to that monster baby,
to Henry's visions of the baby taking his
place, it all goes back to the nightmare of
fatherhood.
Or at least, that's how most people look at
it.
Lynch himself has said the movie is open to
interpretation, saying that "no one, to my
knowledge, has ever seen the film the way
I see it."
Which is exactly the point.
Sometimes with movies, it's not about plot
logic.
It's all about how it makes you feel!
"Can I borrow a feeling?"
"HAHAHA.
"Can I borrow a feeling…
HAHAHA."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!